so of course I I've come to learn that
communion in the Eucharist is um is
something that was practiced weekly yeah
U and it's obviously since the
Protestant Reformation and as things
have progressed up until now that's lost
its way and not only that uh that it's
not practiced weekly anymore but they
also view it as a s as a as a symbolic
representation and something to just
remember but they don't actually believe
that they're partaking in in the body
and in the blood I'm sure you heard this
a million times so U Can you and I don't
know if you have other videos that have
gone deep into this but I was curious if
you can give your reasonings for why we
need to continue to believe that it is
not symbolic and it's in fact literal to
believe it well because the promises of
scripture are clear if the apostles by
the
spirited successors and that's in 1
Timothy I'm sorry 2 Timothy 13- 14 2
Timothy 13- 14 and 2 Timothy 1 chapter
2: 1- 2 2 Timothy 2: 1- 2 2 Timothy 1
13- 14 and 1 Timothy 3:15 where the
apostles by the spirit appoint elders
and Bishops who will have the same Holy
Spirit filling them to guard the flock
and preserve the truth which you can
also find in Acts 20
17-35 but specifically Acts 20
27-30 that means that if these doctrines
are early and Universal then these are
the doctrines that the apostles would
have passed on to the Bishops who then
passed on to the Bishops and they
guarded that deposit by the Pary spirit
and if these doctrines are false then
that means the Bible is a big hoax in a
lie because Jesus was not involved in
building the church and the Holy Spirit
was not with the church to guide the
church and protect the church from error
but agreeing on sound Doctrine and so
the these are the correct doctrines how
in the world are we going to discontin
belie in them when these are the
doctrines that the spirit gave to the
church to
preserve okay and you referenced a
couple of those scriptures in Timothy
and second timothy1 13- 14 where Paul
says to Timothy guard the doctrine that
he received from Paul by the holy spirit
in us and then he tells Timothy what
you've heard from me in the presence of
many witnesses entrust to Reliable men
because it would be Paul appoints a
bishop now Paul dies that Bishop
appoints another Bishop then he dies
that's how it continues and then in 1
Timothy 3:15 we're told that it is the
church the household of God that's the
pillar and foundation of the church the
truth meaning that the body of Believers
presided over by Bishops Acts 20 27- 32
would preserve the truth and Safeguard
it from being perverted so if these
doctrines are early and Universal then
these doctrines must be the truth and
usted by the spirit to the church
otherwise Joe's Witnesses and Mormons
are right second century the church
became so corrupt and apostate it was
lost and then Christ had to restore it
in the 19th
century I see so so those scriptures
that you just gave me those are
scriptures that that talk about how why
those doctrines and how they're going to
be preserved because if if the ukar
became Universal and was the view of the
church and it's wrong then where's the
preservation and so
we and so and and unfortunately I don't
I don't I don't um because I grew up in
the church I don't have all of their
their arguments for it but I just know
that at the end of the day they view it
as symbolic so they can view it any way
they want what I'm saying is if the
correct view is symbolic then the Holy
Spirit allowed the church universally to
accept the wrong view oh I see that
means the Holy Spirit failed or the Holy
Spirit lied either which is blasphemy
gotcha so you're saying regardless of
what they believe if they were right
that means you know the Holy Spirit
failed the church yeah because we
there's a difference between if you have
a few dissenting voices that
disagree and then you have the consensus
the majority or the church universally
agreeing on X for example one thing that
even Protestant historians will admit is
that the church as far back as you can
trace it all agreed even Heretics water
baptism
regenerates it's not not symbolic this
was the universal teaching well wrong it
doesn't
regenerate then where was the Holy
Spirit to safeguard the successors of
the Apostles because Paul said the same
Spirit In Me Is In You Timothy to enable
you to safeguard the deposit of faith
and the spirit is appointing Bishops to
safeguard the flock against Bible
perverts where was the Holy Spirit and
making sure that the church would not
agree on something so false if water
baptism is symbolic
okay no I I I understand that so so it's
clear to me that there's a line that
that's that's clear from the beginning
from the Bible from Paul making that
clear and passing that uh on to Timothy
um so that part is clear now you said
whether or not they believe it's
symbolic that's on them and that would
say a lot of
things to me hold no weight for me
anymore
because the modern church protestantism
is the fruit of the Reformation this why
we have close to 40,000 denominations
it's a fact it's not just this is a fact
so I don't care what Protestant
denominations tell me about these
passages what I want to see is how did
the Church of the first 300 years
because the church was
unified and the Schism started in the
400s so for the first 300 years I want
to see what did the Christians these
Bishops in various places who had
connections with the apostles or the
Disciples of the Bishops appointed by
the apostles what did they say about
baptism infant baptism Mary's Perpetual
virginity her Purity intercession of the
Saints prayers for the dead the
Eucharist they were not Protestants yeah
I mean that didn't really come into play
until like the 1500s I guess yep um so
that that specifically then because it
it does make sense to me that you know
when you partake in the Eucharist you're
partaking in the actual blood and and um
and and the body as it's said in the
book of Acts
um but can you speak
on from scripture can you can you speak
on it just so I know um what why should
we believe in it literally because I I
read the book of Acts I read the book of
Luke and I read um that's the first
gospel I've read and the book of Acts
yeah I'm answering you the church took
it literally they took Jesus's word this
is my body this is my blood
literally okay they just took it
literally so there was no reason to
believe otherwise they didn't allegorize
it they didn't
take it figuratively allegorically they
took it literally I see in fact you'll
find this little interpretation sorry
about that hold on I'm just sorry okay
my my voice to sorry about that you'll
find even the writings of acius of
Antioch Ignatius writing seven letters
to seven churches on his way to being
martyred being killed fed to the animals
willfully gladly for his love for Jesus
Christ who was the Bishop of Antioch who
was a disciple of the apostles who knew
John Peter and Paul and even mentions
the wisom Peter and Paul he talks about
how the Heretics deny that the Eucharist
is the Flesh of Christ and that the
Eucharist being the Flesh of Christ is
the antidote for death so here you have
someone that clearly is interpreting it
as the literal flesh of Christ so where
did the church get it when Jesus says
this is my body this is my blood they
didn't allegorize it they took it
literally in fact even Martin Luther
which is ironic in the 16th
century when he was
debating when he was debating fellow
reformers like UL zwingley who
allegorized the Eucharist he insisted it
is the flesh and blood of Christ because
the flesh and blood of Christ becomes
conjoined to the bread and the cup and
he quotes when Jesus says this is my
body he means it that's what Martin
Luther argued yeah I think I I remember
um father Josiah uh um I don't know if
you're familiar with him but the
Orthodox Church
yes yeah TR trenum I remember him
mentioning the same thing uh on Martin
Luther um okay no that that I I really
appreciate you diving into that and kind
of simplifying it sometimes I try to
over complicate it and it's really
nothing more than the fact that the
church took it literally um in other
words look to the early Christians to
see how they interpret the scripture so
you come to one of two conclusions
either they all got it wrong then that's
an assault against Christ because
where's this promise to save got their
Church from adopting heretical teachings
and false understanding of baptism and
the Eucharist or they got it right and
protestantism is what screwed up yeah
yeah it doesn't seem very
likely yeah that's my journey because I
can't because the just to let you know
this the restorationist movements are
the Mormons the Adventists right and the
millerites which are also campbellites
millerites C millerites became the
Adventist campbellites are the Churches
of Christ they're called restorationist
movements and they started flourishing
in the 19th century because they believe
Christ had to restore the church
restoration because the church became
corrupt and was lost from the second
century it was gone yeah that's
blasphemy because that means Jesus was
either powerless or lied to preserve his
church so you either end up with Christ
did not preserve his
church did a terrible job or lied that
he would or that means these doctrines
which are early must be the true
understanding because Christ is
preserving the church and it's the
reformers and the restoration movements
that are the Heretics and the Bible
perverts yeah I didn't know that kind of
in terms of how the terms came about the
restoration movement that's what it
means Church Christ but then you ask
which of you is restoring Church Mor say
well Joseph Smith ad says no us Jose
witness they all claim to be that
movement that God appointed to restore
the true church